what's going on guys today we got new
information about my
academia movie 3 including comments from
harukoshi himself about the movie
and a time frame for when it will be
released a couple days ago we got three
teaser posters that combined together to
make one bigger poster
and this has been followed by new info
in the shonen jump magazine
just before we get into the details for
those of you who are interested in
reading the official myhero manga online
then i have a special black friday deal
for you that can help you catch up on
the latest storylines
from literally anywhere in the world you
might be with the help of nordvpn
nord has thousands of servers all around
the world which you can access on
windows
mac ios and android devices nordvpn
encrypts your information so everything
you do online is private
and when you choose from one of over 5
000 servers worldwide
you can browse the internet as if you're
coming from that country
if you go to nordvpn.com turtlequirk
you'll get 68
off their 2-year subscription plus for a
limited time
you get an additional 4 months
completely for free
whatever country you're from with
nordvpn you can read manga
or watch anime that is not normally
available in your
region for example you could access the
latest official my hero chapters
for free on viz.com no matter where you
are in the world
i was incredibly happy that nord
sponsored this video because i had a lot
of experience using them already as
before i moved into my own place when i
was at my parents
i i used this app to get around the
parental restrictions on the wi-fi
even though i was a legal adult at the
time but it was just one of those things
you have to do
it let me access websites that i wasn't
able to otherwise and now today i just
use it to protect my privacy
when browsing the web again thanks to
nord for sponsoring this video
and remember there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee so you literally have nothing
to lose
if you want to get this special holiday
deal then be sure to go to nordvpn.com
turtlequirk moving on to the release
date for my hero movie 3
it was confirmed in the latest edition
of weekly shonen jump
that the new my hero academia movie will
release in summer 2021
in japan i think it's safe to say this
means july of 2021
as i imagine they'd want to release the
movie when japanese schools break up for
summer
in terms of worldwide release dates we
can imagine that my hero movie 3 should
come out from september 2021 onwards
as when we look at heroes rising you
know that only began to come out
worldwide
around two months after at least in
japan so in my opinion
september is when we're gonna get it in
most other countries like if you don't
live in japan
you're probably going to get it in
september or later than that or
maybe not at all i don't know but i
guess we'll we'll wait and see we'll
wait and see
when we look at my academia season 5 now
that begins in the spring and it will
continue on a weekly schedule of just
one episode a week
and when we look at the last two my hero
seasons that began
in the spring they were releasing
episodes all the way up until late
september
this kind of made me think a little bit
because the worldwide release of the
movie
could be you know around september time
which means that the movie
could be released at the same time as
the endeavor agency arc is airing
for those that don't know the endeavor
agency arc is when bakugou
shoto and midoriya did an internship
with endeavour
and in the manga most of that internship
was skipped over you know we didn't see
most of the days they were with him if
this movie comes out in september
then there's a high chance its release
would coincide with
that arc happening in the anime and it's
possible that the movie will
fill in gaps that the anime leaves out
now moving on to harukoshi's comments
about the third movie
i'm gonna put it on screen here so it
says we're going to do a third movie
thank you so much for always supporting
deku and the others up until now
during the second movie announcement i
might have commented something like
there will be no more movies
but apparently there is i'm being
supported by so many people
since i couldn't sleep no matter in what
direction i put my feet on
i sleep with handstand position uh okay
yeah so
putting that last comment aside about
him sleeping in a handstand position he
did say
that he he thought hero's rising would
be the last movie
if we look at his reasoning for that the
reason he said that was because the
ending of heroes rising
was so epic that he didn't think he
could surpass it
and he was even afraid because the
ending of heroes rising was something
that he had planned
for the ending of my hero academia so he
was like he had to think of a new ending
for the manga
and obviously to surpass something like
that for another movie
whilst also not stealing ideas away from
the manga finale
it's difficult it's difficult to one-up
yourself every time
but you know what these movies they're
clearly doing well so i feel like as
long as they keep doing well we're gonna
keep getting more movies
but i just really hope it doesn't affect
season six
because season six will be the best
season of all time
so i really hope that whatever movie is
coming out that year
it just doesn't affect season six or
maybe they skip the movie for that year
you just
you just have to make season six great
because it has the material
to be the best ever let me know what you
guys think of this information
are you excited for september 2021
or do you live in japan and you're
excited for july most likely
of 2021 let me know your thoughts down
below and of course if you want to get
68
off nordvpn whilst also getting an
additional four months completely for
free
then do be sure to go to noahvpn.com
turtlequirk
until the next one peace out